Good morning John; I'm leaving town.
I'm exited about this; just got to get away.
(music plays)
(singing)
Country roads, take me home
To the place I belong
Hank: There's like a John Denver song about
Montana and I decided not to sing it.
Katherine: Nope.
Hank: I... why did I do that?
Katherine: I don't know.
(music)
Hank: Our trip thus far has been narrated
entirely by Cecil Baldwin.
Cecil: Just a blinking light-
Hank: Huh!
Cecil: Red
Hank: It's yellow.
Point the camera at yourself, I wan to see
how beautiful my wife is.
(Laughs)
Hank (voice over): Katherine and I were driving
about 150 miles to a place called Freezeout
Lake.
Every year hundreds of thousands of snow geese,
swans, and other water fowl stopped there,
just as the lake starts to thaw, to fatten
up on harvested barley fields.
But first, we stopped at a farm owned by our
friends Jacob and Courtney.
Hank: This here is my friends Jacob and Courtney's
farm; we're on the Rocky Mountain Front, which
is uhh, the land that happens before you get
to the Rocky Mountains, which are over there.
And the from here on out uhh, it's just err...
mostly just corn.
And wheat.
And wheat by-products.
(music)
...you took from the shore
They're easy fears, dear
Hank: Oh you're on me!
(Hank laughs) Oh man.
thanks.
(music)
Will you bury me in a far-off field?
Fresh and lovely darling
Hank: Jacob's gonna show me the garlic trick.
What are you doing?
Ohh.
Whaaaaat?
Jacob: Look at that!
Hank: That does not work with the garlic you
buy at stores, I have to say.
Oh god yeah, just like the most delicious
toothpaste of all time.
I personally hate Daylight Savings Time, and
I think it's ridiculous and we should never
do it.
It was created for farmers; you are farmers.
How do you feel about this?
Jacob: I don't like it.
Courtney: It's hell on babies.
Hank: Okay, well I'm glad we got that settled.
I think we should just take this tape to Congress.
That was fun.
(Katherine burps) Bless you baby.
(voice over)
The early bird catches the geese as they say.
So we were up early the next morning.
Hank: Sunrise in Montana.
The Rocky Mountain Front is generally a very
windy place, which we are experiencing today.
(voice Over)
When we arrived at the lake, there were plenty
of water fowl to be seen but not a goose in
sight, and we were worried that maybe they
were either gone or they hadn't arrived yet.
We were early for the goose migration season,
but we figured we'd take the chance and it
looked like it wasn't gonna pay off.
Then we got kind of lost driving around on
back roads through a horse pasture, and I'd
pretty much given up on seeing the goose migration.
There were horses though, and swans; it was
beautiful, but then there...
right ahead of us.
(music; geese honks)
Hank: Katherine just died.
(laughs) Of happy.
(laughs)